[Applaudissements]
savez ce n'est pas vous qui allez
décider sont les téléspectateurs à
suivre à partir et je vous le dis j'ai
la valise j'ai tout pris al-arich
l'intérieur comme si ça crée de bénef
et on va voir que tu qui la battait
alors je vous dis tout de suite la
personne partira dès ce soir
elle part elle par là là je vous le dis
et parfois partira demain matin donc ce
soir elle dort à l'hôtel
elle part demain par le premier avion et
elle part à miami direccte directions
les ensevelit c'est là une vie s'agit
parfois si elle a une voix je pourrais
bien elle elle partira je voulais
attention qui a été choisi dans
l'enquêté choisi pour aller rejoindre
les anges
la nouvelle saison tu as énergie vous
dis passera trois jours avec eux y
reviendra lundi
d'accord mais chéri dans l'émission qui
a été choisi s'il vous plaît j'aimerais
qu'on ait le sondage merci à céret moi
je froisse jean michel vous avez l'air
inquiet bah oui quand on sait que c'est
vous à présent mais en même temps je
réussisse et mathieu c'est mathieu qui
parlera tension est répartie on y va
s'il vous plaît
le sondage alors abeba selon me jean
michel lambert
les est la production les escrocs jamais
son école et de cristal qui est en régie
exceptionnellement douce moitié rejoint
les jean-louis à 56% non le oui a gagné
jean michel vous partez vous partirez
commun sinon michel il partira
n'obtiendra tout plaisir j'en avais
entendu de jean-michel merci à la
production de l'accueillir merci voilà
mes chéris j'envie red bull est content
non mais dans l'absolu je suis content
parce que c'est du boulot génial non
mais non mais je vous jure que c'est
vrai vous partie demain c'est pas de nom
mais ça ne devrait faire ça sur fond
vert maintenant vraiment je vous le jure
vous serez amené à me jean michaud il se
trouve que j'ai une fille puis 16 ans
déjà mais je vous l'avons ce soir est
bien là mais on peut dire avec vous et
l'école elle passe le bac sans raisons
qui m'ont aidé
[Applaudissements]